we have this tweet from Jason Martinez
he says a North Philly owner says he's
had enough violent crime at his gas
station so he's hired these guys to
protect his customers in store does this
make you feel safer or uncomfortable uh
let me just say I will show you this
this guy right here he's got a mask on
he's got what looks like an AR pistol I
think it's a Glock mag so probably not
with nine millimeter and you take a look
at what we got here there's another guy
here this this fella over here what has
he got he's got I'm not sure you guys
you guys probably know better than me is
that a Bullpup 12 gauge uh no probably
not probably not I don't know what that
is it's a Bullpup something or other but
I gotta be honest I feel a whole lot
safer at those guys standing around I'm
going to get gas and there's two dudes
with rifles I'm gonna feel pretty good
you know better than if they weren't
there in these situations that's that's
true and I also am like okay it's better
than no security but that is the
slippery slope of private security is at
first it feels good because it's better
than none but then all of a sudden
there's going to be six guys then
there's 14 guys then a corporation comes
in and is running the show that then the
owner of the corporation decides now
this gas station's my gas station and
who's there to stop them so like you got
to be real careful with private security
you're describing governments Ian yeah
some people someone said Bullpup 556
someone said Bullpup 12 gauge
uh I'm not sure I think it's a 12 gauge
I thought I thought it was a shotgun
yeah 12 gauge Bullpup shotgun and then
that's obviously a Glock mag in there
yes so it's like an AR pistol or
whatever what's you you were in Philly
right did you see this stuff going on I
was in Philly three weeks ago I didn't
see this type of stuff going on but what
I did see on the streets of Philly was
absolutely horrific now for viewers who
aren't familiar with me again I have
reported in the Bronx on Skid Row in
Portland in the course of two hours of
reporting on Portland I watched a man
overdose in front of me and a woman's
store get robbed I immediately went and
I interviewed the business owner and she
said oh this happens two to three times
a day I interviewed a police officer as
the guy was overdosing he says oh this
happens three to four times a day it's
not a big deal during the summer uh
we'll have four to five overdoses within
the course of one block at the same time
not a big deal going to Philadelphia was
probably one of the most horrific places
I have ever reported on it was
terrifying and I completely understand
the need to have this type of private
security when I was in Philadelphia I
was reporting on their needle exchange
program I was assaulted for reporting on
a public Street I had my equipment
smashed I was slapped in the face I had
urine splashed on me my friend was
calling the police to which I laughed
and responded why are you calling the
police they don't exist here you think
the cops are going to come and care that
I got slapped in the face you have
people getting executed on the streets
in Philly my friend actually sent me a
video just the other day the exact
location I was reporting in a security
guard shot in the back of the head
execution style in the exact place that
I was that's what's happening on the
Streets of Philadelphia every single day
the police do not exist there the police
do not exist in Portland where back in
2020 they decriminalized hard drugs and
you can go shoot up heroin in front of a
police officer in Los Angeles in San
Francisco in Portland Oregon the police
don't exist in these areas so I
completely understand uh you know these
private security members being hired
take a look at this right here so a
couple people have said 100 12 gauge
some people have said Bullpup 556. it uh
it looks like a Tavor 12 gauge Bullpup
is that what it is because it looks very
much like one that I have and I'm
looking at that Barrel what do you think
Luke well there's a Trevor
um 556 but I don't think that's it
um I think it's it's a it's a Bullpup
yeah I don't know who makes it and
produces it I've got one I got a Bullpup
shotgun looks just like that yeah yeah
that makes more sense to me
but yeah what's the accurate range on
that thing well it depends what you're
shooting would you classify that as an
assault rifle they do it looks very
scary they they assault like they insult
shotgun salt shot yeah of course
absolutely like if it has a pistol grip
and a rifle and a rifle stock it's an
assault weapon the good thing tin is um
you know all this gas station really had
to do was say this is a gun-free zone
and then the criminals wouldn't go and
attack them so it's kind of their own
fault for not putting up that sign
because we all know that that's the most
simplistic way to stop crying by
screaming please don't yeah that's
worked throughout the years this is a
gun-free zone the Karma's like oh my bad
it stopped Genghis Khan actually wait no
it didn't Nothing Stops it's also
important to know something Ian times
time so it's a beautiful wife while this
is happening in Pennsylvania in places
like New York City they're spending uh
government resources there going up in
Times Square and making sure to notify
people that they cannot legally carry
arms and that Times Square is a gun-free
zone essentially saying hey criminals if
you do have a gun which most criminals
you do during during this crazy day and
age and they don't follow the gun laws
that if they have any victims there the
victims won't be able to defend
themselves that's essentially what
they're saying that's essentially what
they're doing at least Pennsylvania
they're still as of right now some kind
of semblance of ability of human beings
to be able to defend themselves and
sadly we're going towards a society
where if you have money you could have
protection you could have security if
you don't have money you're screwed you
know what my favorite thing is is when
politicians like ilhan Omar who call to
abolish the police are then surrounded
by private security oh yeah I always
love to see it I grew up with this in
Chicago all these politicians would be
alive guns should be banned and then
they're allowed to carry guns
politicians and then and not only that
they have the rich people the the
wealthy Democrat types voting for the
stuff have armed guards it's like uh you
know when the Pelosi's were shocked that
a crazed crackhead in San Francisco
broke into their home it's like
congratulations that's what happens to
the people of San Francisco every day
you're not special talking about that
dude that apparently hit Paul Pelosi
with a hammer I feel like they're
they're railroading that guy like I
think Paul knew that guy in their room
he's claiming the Genesis yeah he said
he was innocent Paul was smiling and
laughing interesting story you know I
heard that security guard you mentioned
that got X you thought got executed and
I heard he survived oh God execution
style okay yeah but I think he survived
is what good came up on this on the show
a little while ago yeah I wonder if like
I don't know I think I think like Media
Matters wrote something about we were
talking about the Paul Pelosi attack and
they wrote some nonsense where it's like
they believe weird conspiracies and I
was like the whole segment was that we
didn't know what really happened because
the police keep changing their story but
if you in any way question the narrative
that means you're a conspiracy theorist
it's like bro I don't have a theory I
was like the police changed their story
we don't know what happened my favorite
thing was when what was it MSNBC or NBC
uh suspended their own reporter for
accidentally telling the truth about
that story all right he's still gone
he's still suspended to tell the truth
on a mainstream don't do it don't do it
guys could you imagine like your
reporter and you get a email it's like
come to the come to HR and they're like
yeah Miguel we have troubling reporting
coming in from co-workers did you tell
the truth on air well I I did
I'm sorry you know but thank you for
being honest or or not you're suspended
it's like look it specifically says on
line four of your contract that you're
not supposed to tell the truth so you're
gonna have to get fired sorry sorry my
guy they like they throw they have like
a sarlacc pit and they're like at least
push them in dude that's our media it's
like how you know Amy Robuck is
currently in the news right now for
having an affair with one of her
co-hosts but she wasn't in the news back
in what two years ago when she knew
about Jeffrey Epstein and kind of just
overlooked it really it's amazing well
let's break that down I mean you get uh
this she gets she gets booted I think it
was Daily Mail that found out that so
this is an ABC news anchor her and her
co-host were like hooking up and I think
like they got a photo of him smacking
her butt or something yeah so they take
her off the air yeah but when she got
caught when she was on a hot mic and
camera talking about how they had the
Epstein story and veritas releases this
they're alive how she had the clintons
how she had victims coming forward how
she had to feel horrible after
interviewing having these women women
trust her to do this story and then let
them down because some executive at ABC
said no we're going to be protecting
this larger child trafficking and
extortion operation which is being
protected by the intelligence agencies
come on but enough here is where we draw
the line yes can't do that can't do that
absolutely disgusting society that that
again has a lot of hypocrisy in it and
if you and this is what we know imagine
what we don't know imagine all the
things that are happening behind the
scenes that we that are still being done
in secret that it's still uh unknown to
the general public you can only imagine
how more debaterous how more insane
things get dude the fact that we saw the
entire Balenciaga campaign just you know
out and open to the public it's like I
don't know if I want to know what we
don't know I'd rather know
um I have my I have my theories I like
to talk about some of these theories but
uh I can't sometimes on YouTube are they
are they conspiracy theories
um I think the conspiracy theories now
are spoiler alert uh for the general
public because when we look at what's
been happening in the last few years I
mean it's just time after time the the
whole agenda the whole narrative has
been collapsing everything that they try
to shove down our throat everything that
they're trying to tell us is lies and
and it's all being unraveled every
single day it's crazy remember when Alex
Jones went on Rogan and talked about
like multi-dimensional beings cell
towers hybrids I'm just like at this
point I'm I have I have very little
doubt left in me now I'm kind of just
like you know I don't know dude if
Hillary Clinton shed her skin on camera
and became a lizard person I'd be like
I'm not surprised I get it
another Penny in The Alex Jones
blinks like her eyes go like that you
know you're just like yeah old news we
already knew her tongue comes out licks
her eye you're like picks up the loogie
she puts in her glass
you know what they're doing it for it's
so that when the aliens land we go
uh-huh we get it just land which they've
already been releasing these documents
like oh the government has been uh
talking to FB or alien you know entities
for years and everyone's like cool
yeah proof is I'll believe it when I see
it even then I probably won't believe it
no I think the opposite I'd like an
alien walk up to me I'd be like I'm
sorry I have no doubt left in me you
know what I mean like so much weird
stuff has happened over the past few
years Tim would be like please take me
away please God I mean it depends if it
was like the Federation and they're like
we're gonna leave Earth and it's Petty
nonsense but no what I mean is like it
would be over in the news cycle within a
week oh Hillary Clinton shape-shifted
next week Donald Trump wants to end the
Constitution next week and some other
exactly it bumps you know again it
literally would be just a blip in in our
headlines in the way we're consuming
news it would be page 20 of like the New
York Times and it would be like a small
paragraph like earlier today Hillary
Clinton was revealed to be a
shape-shifting lizard person after
shedding her skin during a campaign run
and it would not even be front page
front page would be like Jim Jim Bob
from West Virginia suspected of being
January 6 Capital rioter front page or
some woke stupid idea about some kind of
actor portrayals or racism or other
Men In Black where they have the
tabloids and they're telling the truth
about what's really going on about the
aliens or whatever and everyone's like
yeah whatever it's fake news that's just
our modern day now I'll just watch this
point is that we're making jokes about
like how shocking it would be if Hillary
Clinton shed her skin we have the Super
Chat from third eye sag who says kind of
like how Cuomo got pushed out of office
over a sex scandal uh instead of
murdering 15 000 people yeah yeah well I
mean why was the government attack him
for that they do that every single day
you know yeah they're probably sitting
around and they're like well the public
is pretty mad that Cuomo killed 15 000
people but we don't want to come down on
them because what if we want to kill 15
000 people later yeah I'm surprised he
didn't get a Noble Peace Prize for that
the government well actually we asked
you to do 30 000 so you came under par
but that's why they actually got him out
yeah they were like we're not gonna get
you out of office for the 15 000. but
you did come in underperforming so we're
gonna use a sex scandal to fire you we
instituted you for depopulation and you
failed so you're fired have fun that's
the crazy that's that's just the
craziest thing you know looking at the
Canadian euthanasia stuff I was looking
at that today it was like Die With Honor
dignity or something oh yeah the media
tries to come out these these corporate
journalists and say like there's no
depopulation agenda and it's like what
do you think what is it called when Bill
Gates goes on stage at a Ted conference
and says if we work really hard we can
reduce global population growth by 15
that's population reduction that's a
depopulation agenda like I don't
understand how that's not a thing when
the dude went on stage at Ted and said
it it's a population retardation meaning
a slowing of the growth of the
population it's not really a reduction
it's more of a sloth everything coming
out of Canada right now is absolutely
insane though I believe I was reading a
story about this 23 year old who had
diabetes in the Canadian government's
response was die yeah that's basically
it now that's our health care System you
should probably just die you know
regarding this government the problems
people have been having with the
government I don't I don't really I'm
confused right now I see the liberal
economic order this is my when I say our
government I consider it the liberal
economic order it's well established
George Bush Senior established it's
transitioning to a new world order it's
a global order now why would they the
liberal economic order go to odds with
Russia when we're trying to create
Global governance in our image why would
we stifle and alienate one of our
greatest potential allies because they
won't bend the knee you need conflict
but Russia and Vladimir Putin have made
statements saying that specifically they
want to be a part of the New World Order
they want to have a seat at the table
and the United States and the other
Western powers are saying no
everything's from us at the table
Russia's saying we just want to sit
there thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time